hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul and
welcome to another edition of mystery
languages if this is your first time
watching a mystery languages video then
let me tell you how it goes
I'll play you a sample of a language or
a couple of samples of a language and
you can listen and guess what each
language might be you might not get the
exact language but you might get the
region or the language family or
something like that and that's a partial
success in itself today's language
samples were submitted by Lange focused
viewers via Instagram so I'm especially
excited about today's episode so let's
get started please listen
yes some value of appra managements new
Virage re-boiler hidey-ho kevorkian in
kakapo clay by tony al-khawaja Darva pot
mutant onion add relieve our stock about
Hakeem use on on the carpets Agricola
Sivaji head now high Otara chin Kotova
constant now let's look at a few samples
with writing yes Suman Grinnell mechanic
at all huh Cousteau now get care trail
Garrard era needs yes champ Joshi I see
echo so what language do you think it
might be
[Music]
the language is Armenian Armenian is the
official language of the Republic of
Armenia but more than half of its
speakers live in other countries in
Armenian minority communities it's a
member of the indo-european language
family but it forms its own branch of
indo-european because its links to other
languages in the family are not really
known but it has borrowed a large amount
of vocabulary from Persian so Persian
speakers might recognize a lot of words
in Armenian the stress in Armenian
generally falls on the final syllable of
the word not always but it usually does
unless the word has the definite article
or a possessive adjective at the end if
we read along with the sentences we
heard before we can notice that the
stress usually comes at the end
yes umem Ganahl mechanikat or how
cousteau on this recording this word
sounds like it has the stress on the
first syllable like tani but in other
sources it sounds more like honey with
the stress on the second syllable that
might depend on the sentence level
stress of this sentence as a whole
nah get care trail gara gara needs yes
champ Joshy I see Eric oh there are two
standard varieties of Armenian Western
Armenian and Eastern Armenian which have
some significant differences the variety
that you heard in the samples was
Eastern Armenian this map shows the
distribution of Western Armenian and
Eastern Armenian dialects at the
beginning of the 20th century but most
speakers of Western Armenian now live in
diaspora communities okay now on to the
next language please listen
why mister last night Mr Mandela cooks
on dumpling and when they say you see
listen I need a picnic or another
dumpling on flannery
in Waianae Galit what the girl giving is
only a man at tennis a pig named
Penelope nibble nibble I love a sort of
movie secondly a policeman second fiddle
man why Annie not good natella say I
mean not good at all where them people
are really really wicked Natalie penis
tickle tickle when I have flown on a
merit LS a girl actually me lick Nutella
said I serve in ela pity garden
now let's look at a few more sentences
with writing they wanna buy some clues
she borrowed a book from the library
we now go on all dinner tonight so what
language could it be the language is
Jamaican Patois as the name suggests
Jamaican Patois
is spoken in Jamaica it has around 3
million native speakers
it's an english-based creole that
developed in the 17th and 18th centuries
through contact between african slaves
and english-speaking slave owners the
official language of Jamaica is English
and Jamaican Patois is spoken on a
continuum with standard Jamaican English
that means that in some situations
speakers will be essentially using
standard English with a characteristic
Jamaican accent well in other situations
speakers will mix English with varying
degrees of patois and at the very casual
end of the spectrum speakers might use
Jamaican Patois
exclusively the three sentences that we
saw on the screen were pretty close to
standard English but the longer reading
that you heard was full-on Jamaican
Patois
but we do see some grammatical and
phonological changes in those three
sentences take the third one for
instance Managua or Deena tonight
Jamaican Patois uses me as the subject
pronoun rather than I the negative is na
instead of not and noticed that there is
a double negative
with no being used where any would be
used in English notice that going to is
abbreviated to go on and of course the
pronunciation is different to Deena and
tonight are close to the standard
English equivalents just with slightly
different pronunciation and spelling to
match and on to the next language please
listen
kuan-yin eh eh yeah we ate the Inigo
alumina and attaboy attaboy
perro Ontario a terracotta classy lady
already caught up eating salmon and you
ought to hear an ample gain the Hayley
has a 300 jana alle alle da la da da la
materia
a technical Mia Azealia Norah para to
Jana Samina unless you Thomas to you
today yeah
next we'll look at a few sentences with
writing a Java SE Shana hi everybody
kept a name you really take away that's
in the more in could we heard a bit so
what language could this possibly be
[Music]
the language is Guarani Guarani is an
indigenous language of South America
it's spoken by over 6 million people
including most of the population of
Paraguay where it's an official language
alongside Spanish it's also spoken in
parts of neighboring Argentina Bolivia
and Brazil it's a member of the 2p
language family which consists of around
70 languages scattered throughout South
America one feature of Guarani that we
can notice is that every syllable
consists of a consonant plus vowel or a
lone vowel a syllable cannot end in a
consonant and there are no consonant
clusters to me this gives the language a
pleasant light floating quality kind of
sing-songy but without tones
another thing that adds to this quality
is granny's nasal sounds Guarani has six
oral vowels and six nasal vowels also
all voiced stops are either pre
nasalized before an oral vowel or
nasalized before a nasal vowel
there's also nasal harmony meaning that
stressed nasal vowels cause other
surrounding sounds to become nasal as
well we can see an example of this in
this sentence
Noah say Shauna this is the word for
clothes and this is a future ethics
showing that the noun will be obtained
in the future this affix has a nasal
vowel which makes the earlier vowels
nasal as well listen for it a u.s.
Asiana a u.s. Asiana all right so let's
check out one final language please
listen tardes shawarma and macaque focus
on Chalmers ferrule Amnon show mercy
Mars fatal Amish Gilligan's fakin
tarantella fish because our maka of
Lamech lon
coma vision is Brahma humor labor
Martian spas Prevot dock at Arkham Dom
fain now let's look at a few samples
with writing the welcome ad iconic for
she'll our air is sucked on Leland Nev
egg dinner gamma nacht
so what language do you think it might
be
[Music]
the language is Irish as you can
probably guess Irish is the historical
language of Ireland it's still spoken as
a native language there by a minority of
people and is learned as a heritage
language by most others to varying
degrees it's also known as Irish Gaelic
and is a member of the Celtic language
family one interesting feature of Irish
is that all consonants have two forms a
broad form and a slender form depending
on the surrounding vowels there are
three broad vowels and three slender
vowels that determine which form of the
consonant is used the slender form of
the consonants are palatalized which
generally sounds like a yeah placed
right after the consonant if we look at
this word Tiana we see this consonant
twice the first is before a narrow vowel
and the second is after a broad vowel
the broad form is huh but the narrow
form is like yeah not ha there are
similar pairs for all consonants we can
see another example of this in the word
jinnia the D sound is next to a narrow
vowel so it's palatalized like deer or
Jill jr. I don't know if all speakers
say the narrow consonants the same way
and to be honest I can't hear it in this
word on the recording we listen to but I
can hear it in this sample from the
fourvel website jr. Dean yeah Daniel
the geniu engineer in this sample we can
hear the narrow D sound as well as a
narrow n which makes the sound yeah well
that's all for today's mystery languages
video thanks to all the Lang focused
viewers who submitted their language
samples via Instagram there will be more
of mystery languages videos in the
future so follow me on Instagram to stay
in the loop
be sure to follow Lange focus on
Facebook Twitter and Instagram
especially Instagram that's my favorite
and that's where you can keep in touch
with me more than the others and once
again thank you to all my patreon
supporters especially these amazing
people right here on the screen they are
the top tier patreon supporters so many
thanks to them as always and to everyone
else thank you for watching and have a
nice day
[Music]